foreign
[Music]
and I'm here today to tell you about a
time that I crashed a database
and I learned some techniques to help
from ever doing that again that I'm
going to share with you
I was working on the 31st floor of an
office building in Downtown Seattle that
had a beautiful view of the Puget Sound
and Olympic mountains
I was working on the marketing analytics
team at a large fashion retailer and I
was working on a project that involved
migrating marketing attribution
reporting from our old click stream
vendor to an in-house solution
this involved doing a backfill
has anyone in the room ever done a data
backfill
yeah I see a few hands has anyone ever
had performance issues with that
backfill
I certainly have
so this project required a backfill of a
year and a half of historical click
stream data
but at this time I had been a data
analyst for about three years and
through that time had written SQL
queries almost every day
so naturally I thought I was an expert
so I sat down at my desk
put on my headphones turned on a score
by Trent rezner
and got to work
I was working in an Amazon redshift
database with page view level website
data and for those of you who may not be
familiar with website data anytime that
you hover or click or view a page it's
generating data so you can imagine that
that can be a pretty large set of data
for a single person not to mention a
website that has millions of visitors a
year
in the past I had worked at health
insurance companies and so I was used to
working with medical claims data
and that data was more in the millions
of rows
this data set was 4 billion rows
so I had my query and I sat I sat down
on my desk and I had my two monitors
on the right hand side I had my SQL IDE
and I set off my backfill
and on my left monitor I had some
documentation open that I was working on
I updated some jira tickets and let's be
honest check my Twitter feed
after getting sucked into that for about
45 minutes I turned to my screen and I
noticed that my query was still running
and I thought hmm
that doesn't seem very good
so I try to cancel it
and I got the rainbow wheel of death and
had to kill it
and then I tried to run it again
and about an hour later
there was still a problem
so I tried to cancel it again
and again it crashed
so I thought to myself what is going on
with this I'm a sequel expert and
obviously my code is perfect so it can't
be anything that I'm doing
on the 31st floor it held the entire
data science and analytics team which
was about 100 people made up of data
analysts engineers and scientists
so I thought it's probably just a busy
time on the database I'm probably
running into some concurrency issues and
it's just slow in general
then I had a brilliant idea I'll just
run it at night
traffic on the database will be low and
everything will be fine
so I went home took the bus
and before I went to bed that night I
set off my query to run into the night
I woke up a little bit early the next
morning to a slack notification on my
phone
from the database administrator
who had never direct messaged me before
and all it said was hi
oh fudge what have I done
my heart sank because I knew that
something was wrong
it turned out that the query that I ran
ran for over seven hours
and not only that it took compute
resources from other nightly ETL jobs
which made them run slower which made
them finish later
which ended up delaying all of our
business reporting for that day
I was mortified I had not only made my
life harder I had made the databases
like administrator's life harder my
team's life harder because their
stakeholders reporting was delayed as
well
and needless to say the business was not
very happy with me
but lucky for me the DBA reached out to
me and offered to help me rewrite this
query
so I swallowed my pride walked down to
the 25th floor where the engineering
team sat
pulled up a chair and had a one hour
meeting that changed the course of my
sequel life forever
and what I learned I'm going to share
with you today
imagine for a second that you're going
to explore a dark cave
what items might you want to help you
for me I would want to map
I would want to know where I'm going
does this cave even have an exit how
many tunnels are there
I would also want a team or a cavern
crew I would want people to help carry
equipment and make the journey easier
it's also very dark in this cave so a
flashlight would be helpful to be able
to see where I'm going
an explain plan is like a map
it returns a step-by-step list of
actions that your query will take to
return your data set
it also Returns the estimated
computational cost of that query
it's very easy to run you only have to
put the word explain in front of your
query and run it
the first time I saw an explain plan I
was very overwhelmed I swear my head
exploded
but it turns out that it's a very
helpful tool because that computational
cost can help you understand if changes
that you're making to your query are
helpful
so in my instance where I would run my
query wait an hour kill it run it wait
an hour kill it if I had run explain
plans I could see that the changes that
I would make it that I was making
were would reduce the computational cost
without having to wait that extra hour
so explain plans are very useful
for our Cavern crew or cave team
we want everyone to be contributing
equally
we don't want one person to be carrying
all of the backpacks and the other
people to not be carrying anything that
doesn't seem one very nice or two very
efficient
from a query perspective
compute nodes are like your cave team
you want all of your compute nodes
contributing equally and leveraging all
of their resources
to make sure that happens you need to
appropriately specify the distribution
Style
distribution means that your data is
properly distributed across no the
compute nodes and does not have
significant skew
but how do you do that how do you know
what's the right distribution Style
you think about which column you're
going to join on
if you're planning on joining on a
unique ID such as an order ID or a
customer ID
then this style key is what you want to
use
and the choice of your dist key depends
on which column you are going to use to
join to another data set
to style all
is very dangerous
it copies your data across each of the
compute nodes so
in the case where you're not going to
join your table to anything ever and
it's a small data set you can get away
with this style all but I personally
wouldn't recommend it
um and if you're not sure what you're
going to join on maybe you have a table
that's a lot of rows but it doesn't have
a good unique ID or a candidate for a
disk key
and maybe it's a combination of fields
that's making it have a lot of rows then
to style even is a good candidate
and the beauty of the explain plan is
that when we make these changes to our
table and try to run our query we can
run an explain plan to know if those
changes actually made a difference
so caution with this doll
your sort key is like a flashlight
it helps you only search relevant data
imagine that you have a data set that
has three years of data 2020 2021 and
2022.
I only care about 2022. I'm living in
the present so I have a where I have a
where Clause that filters on where year
equals 2022.
and my result set would be filtered
however if I am not if the table I'm
querying from does not have a sort key
even though my result set is filtered it
the query had to scan the entire table
to find it
which is not very efficient
and so when you specify a sort key it
helps your query know immediately where
to find the data that you're looking for
so it reduces the computation needed to
pull back your result set
to decide on a sort key you think about
which column you will filter on
a lot of times that's a date
this is an example of the data set that
I was working with on that fateful night
when I ruined everything
there's a user ID a session ID an event
ID and an event time
there's also an event type and a
marketing tag I was working on the
marketing analytics team and so I cared
about traffic and sales driven by
marketing
based on what we just learned we know
that distribution style key is a good
fit for this table because it has unique
identifiers
but which unique identifier would we
choose as a dist key
the answer is it depends
if I was keeping the data set at this
level
I would want to join I would want to
specify the disk key as the most
granular ID
I with using this data set I would
likely join on the event ID to another
table
so therefore it should be the dist key
pulling together everything that we have
learned on the left hand side I have a
query that takes that page view level
data that we were just looking at and
Aggregates it to the session level
if you can imagine landing on a website
you can have multiple page views doing a
session and so I cared about what
marketing is at the session level
and so when I'm creating it this
temporary table
I've specified my distribution style as
key and I've specified my disk key as
session ID because that's what I'm going
to use to join to another data set
so I know that my all my compute nodes
will be contributing equally
I also have my flashlight or my sort key
on session start time
because that's what I'm going to use
when I end up filtering from this
temporary table
on the right I have a query that
leverages the table that I just created
and joins it to another
table called Web orders
and I'm joining to that table on user ID
and session ID
the because we have specified session ID
as the distribution key all of the
compute nodes will be used in this join
and it will make it run much more
efficiently
because we have the sort key specified
as session start time I'm filtering on
anything greater than January 1st of
2022 and so therefore
my query doesn't have to search for data
that it doesn't care about
and we've saved time there as well
we've run our query
we have our result set
in a reasonable amount of time
we've made it to the light at the end of
the tunnel and the other side of the
cave
which is a big win
some other wins that came out of this
experience
for one my query that had run overnight
for seven hours
ended up running in under one hour
during a high traffic time on the
database so ultimately the run time was
reduced by six hours because of these
changes
I also built a strong relationship with
the database administrator that was very
useful for future cross-functional
projects between the data science team
and the engineering team
but my favorite lesson came from I
documented my findings
and I shared it back with my team
I helped them learn these techniques and
apply them to their own queries to avoid
making the mistakes that I made
and through that process of sharing my
experience with my team
it also helped me have a paradigm shift
towards embracing mistakes because
mistakes
even varied business
negative impacting ones can help you
learn a lot
so if you find yourself with a
long-running query
there are a few things you can do
you can run an explain plan
you can check the distribution Style
and you can specify sort keys
and that is how you can save hours of
time with just a few lines of code
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]